who made millions of dollars from the
attack on Israel look at this chart it
shows bets against Israeli stocks on the
New York Stock Market this big rise in
shorts as the bets are called happened a
few days before the attack on Israel on
October 7th someone may have been
betting that something was about to push
down the value of Israeli stocks and in
just two trades they could have made a
million dollar the timing could suggest
knowledge of the forthcoming attack is
it possible that someone in Hamas was
behind it
to figure out what happened consider
trades made in a fund of Israeli shares
on the New York Stock Exchange in
September around 1,600 shares were
shorted per day in this fund but on
October 2nd it was around
227,000 mainly from just two trades
that's pretty unusual especially as one
of the only other times it's happened
was just before Passover which according
to an Israeli TV station was the date
originally planned for the oct October
attack so could it be that Hamas was
Behind These trades its Financial Empire
brings in over a billion dollars a year
so it seems unlikely it would take such
a big risk for such a small
sum we are talking potential profits in
the singled digigit Millions by the
scale of Hamas the finances of Hamas
that is a drop in the bucket it is
unfathomable that Hamas would risk
detection of their attack to make $1
million on the New York Stock Exchange
so what's going on perhaps it was all
entirely innocent somebody May simply
have been seeking to close a big
position on the first trading day of a
quarter because both uh the trading on
this day and the trading in April right
before Passover happened to fall on the
first day of a quarter but it is
certainly not the most likely
explanation given the timing or perhaps
details of the attacks were leaked Hamas
kept sufficiently tight operational
security to fool the Israelis and
foreign intelligence Services as well um
but it is certainly possible that some
tidbit of information leaked out to
someone who was able to profit from it
it could be that this was just the tip
of the iceberg one possibility is that
someone made a lot more money off this
then we can't measure it maybe they made
a bigger bet against Israeli assets in
some other Market that was not trackable
in public data explaining every move in
financial markets is
hard but it is at least plausible that
whoever made the trades had some
knowledge of what was to
[Music]
come